you're a bit of a high-strung person you
see what yeah and you're you knows you
use the F you'll drop an f-bomb at the
drop of a hat I'm just curious if that's
something that plagues you in your life
would you say that's true you're a
little bit high-strung this is rude but
I will answer this question yes i but i
never yes you are I meditate I meditate
now and and I'm that helps you know
actually there's one day I met a teen I
went to like a zone and I like I feel
great and I was like if I didn't have to
leave the house today like [ __ ] you
don't be perfect but I had to go
somewhere and I was driving actually
felt so good for meditating that I kind
of zoned out and like slowed down the
green light instead of when you're
supposed to go and this guy in back of
me got pissed and he beeped and then
like we met up at the next light and he
just goes what were you doing at the
light dumbass and I was like what yeah
and I was like but I meditated today and
so I just kind of smiled at him cuz
that's why you meditate right as you're
sure - I feel better than others I was
like and then it just like the angry
Boston girl I mean was like no F this
guy and so I go I stood up in the car
and I went through the sunroof and I
went into the passenger seat and I went
what the
and we started having a fight and it
goes what were you doing at the light
and I wanted to make him feel bad sure
so I go I just found out my mother died
which wasn't true she had so you know he
goes to me he goes you still a dumbass
see y'all getting back on my side yeah
your mother died not true but then he
said you're still a dummy
yeah so I was like so anyway I just
started screaming at him and he drove
off and went you're crazy and I was like
like do not call a woman crazy unless
you want to see your go effing crazy you
know and so anyway and then I realized
well I'm Stan Lee sometimes you say the
f-word and other times you say effing
it's his crazy yeah we never know what's
gonna happen
that gettin the F word are we getting
the real thing you know I just might I
don't want to give the censors too much
to do yeah yes so we where that was it
we we drove off and then we met up at
the next light and he goes hey I'm sorry
and I go that's alright and he goes
about your mom and I go oh right I had
totally forgotten what came out of my
mouth as I go yeah it's been a rough
morning so much paperwork not a good
first yeah
you